a new toxin has been found to kill
cancerous cells while ignoring healthy
ones and it comes from Brazilian wasps
and meet the Hedgehog a robot designed
to explore the surface of a comet Vsauce
Kevin here this is mine flow
researchers at UCLA have helped a
paralyzed man walk by stimulating his
nerves and putting him in a bionic suit
by combining a treatment called epidural
electrical stimulation with the nerve
stimulating drug the team was able to
train Marc Pollux nerves to have a
higher motor threshold so they could
connect to the brain the treatment is a
proof-of-concept in the suit acts like
training wheels supporting the patient's
legs and adjusting itself based on how
much assistance is needed aside from
walking the treatment appears to improve
blood pressure heart rate and bladder
function to raise the quality of life
for quadriplegics it's ER 9 is a website
designed to create an immortal digital
version of yourself it learns about your
posting habits and use of language to
create what they call your counterpart a
virtual artificial intelligence that
will post on your behalf even when
you're not signed on and will continue
to keep posting after you die virtual
robots are being used to study how
cooperation amongst certain insects
evolved the robots were placed in a
virtual environment that simulated a
tree with falling leaves and then
observed over many generations while
initially the robots behaviors were
erratic after 2000 generations of
digital breeding the robots had
developed specialized tasks despite all
starting with the same programming this
discovery not only sheds light on the
evolution of insects but also suggests
that simulations could be used to
improve and adapt real swarms of
unspecified robots to specific tasks the
IceCube Observatory in Antarctica has
confirmed the existence of cosmic
neutrinos neutrinos are high-energy
particles that are nearly impossible to
detect due to their ability to pass
through almost anything unaffected
detecting cosmic neutrinos is important
because they're able to carry
information across the universe like the
origins of high-energy cosmic rays and
can even alert us to the presence of
supernovae before they're visible from
Earth the climate engineering firm
transpolar has created a membrane that
could cool entire cities these photonic
membranes reflect incoming sunlight back
into space and convert the heat into
infrared light without the use of
electricity or water they could be used
to cool large areas sustainably and
there's currently
installation in Paris showcasing it that
runs until October 4th the solar
sunflower is a hyper efficient way of
harnessing solar energy with an energy
efficiency of 80% it uses a liquid
cooling system to draw heat away from
the solar collectors so that it doesn't
overheat a single device could power two
to four houses but as of now concerns
over its cost and functionality without
direct sunlight could keep it from
seeing commercial use real virtuality
combines motion capture technology with
VR headsets it allows for multiple users
to interact with a virtual environment
and each other in real time the
rendering of the environment happened so
quickly that two users can toss a torch
to each other without having to remove
their headsets this represents a huge
step in virtual reality gaming and can
also change the way soldiers
firefighters and many other professions
are trained researchers at University of
San Diego have created 3d printed
microscopic fish designed for medical
purposes these microscope fish use iron
oxide and platinum nanoparticles in
their head and tail to change direction
and speed they're chemically powered
magnetically steered and could be used
to deliver medicine to different parts
of the body or to sense and remove
toxins meanwhile researchers at Penn
State have created a polymer that self
heals when it comes into contact with
water and it's made with genes from a
squid the team found that squid teeth
possessed self-healing proteins which
they were able to replicate in the lab
and they hope to use this to create
underwater fiber-optic cables that can
be repaired because currently if one
breaks the cable must be completely
replaced finally mit has invented a 3d
printer that can print 10 different
materials simultaneous with multifamily
integrate these two worlds of
traditional manufacturing and 3d
printing by putting them together you
you can create whole new range of
objects that we haven't been able to
make to it
I'm gonna leave you with printing glass
and as always thanks for watching